is there advice that you can give to
young people today whether in high
school or college who are thinking about
their career
or thinking about life
how how to live
a life they're proud of a successful
life
yeah so so many people ask me for advice
and have asked and i give i talk to a
lot of people all the time
and there is no one way
you know there's a lot of pressure
to
produce papers
that will be acceptable and be published
uh maybe i was maybe i'd come from an
age where i would i could be a rebel
against that
and and still succeed maybe it's harder
today
but i think it's important not to get
too caught up
with
what everyone else is doing
and
if you if well it depends on what you
want of life if you want to
have real impact
you have to be ready to fail
a lot of times so you have to make a lot
of unsafe decisions
and the only way to make that work is to
make keep doing it for a long time and
then one of them will be work out and so
that that will make something successful
or not
oh yeah or you may or you just may you
know end up you know not having a you
know having a lousy career i mean that's
it's certainly possible taking the risk
because the thing yeah so but it it
but there's no way to to um
make all safe decisions and actually
really contribute
do you uh
think about your death by your mortality
i gotta say when covert hit
i did because we did you know in the
early days we didn't know how bad it was
gonna be and i
that that made me work on my book harder
for a while but then i'd started this
company and now i'm doing full-time more
than full-time in the company so the
book's on hold but i do want to finish
this book um when you think about it are
you afraid of it
i'm afraid of dribbling
you know
of losing the details of okay yeah
yeah but the fact that the ride ends
i've known that for a long time um so
it's
yeah but there's knowing and knowing
it's such a
yeah and it really sucks it feels it
feels a lot closer
so my in in my my blog with my
predictions my sort of back against that
was that because i said
i'm going to review these every year for
32 years and that puts me into my
mid-90s so you know it's my
whole every every time you write the
blog post you're getting closer and
closer to your own prediction that's
that's true of your death yeah
yeah what do you hope your legacy is
you're one of the greatest roboticist ai
researchers of all time
um
what i hope is that i actually
finished writing this book
and that
there's a there's one person
who reads it
and sees something
about changing the way they're thinking
and that leads to
the next
big
and then they'll be
on a podcast 100 years from now saying i
once read that book
and that changed everything
you